[موسيقى]
هي في القلب بين قارات العالم رسما ووصفا
تطويف احشائها نحو الثلوث ثروات العالم
المعدنيه وتملك خمسه وستين في المئه من
الاراضي الصالحه للزراعه في العالم رغم
هذه الثروات تعاني شعوبها اسوا معدلات
الفقر ومن الصراعات والنزاحات انها القاره
السمراء افريقيا وقد باتت في الشهور
الاخيره محور اهتمام بلوه تنافس دولي فاثر
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا زار العديد من
دولها الرئيس الفرنسي والمستشار الالماني
وزراء خارجيه الولايات المتحده وروسيا
والصين وحقدت اواخر العام الماضي في
واشنطن قمه امريكيه افريقيه بقصتنا الليله
التنافس الدولي على افريقيا نستطيع اراء
خبراء امريكيين وروس وصينيين حول دوافع
دولهم الى الاتجاه الى افريقيا والاهميه
السياسيه والاقتصاديه للقاره والهواجس
المتبادله بينهم كما نتحدث الى وساسه
افارقه حول اسباب تفضيل اللجوء الى الصين
لتطوير البنيه التحتيه في بلدانهم مقارنه
بدول غربيه ونستكمل بقيه القصه في لقاء
خاص مع الرئيس
الانغوليتشو
من حرب اهليه دامت قرابه ثلاثه عقود وكانت
من علامات الاستقطاب الدولي خلال الحرب
البارده لتتجه في السنوات الاخيره الى
التعاون مع الصين والبرازيل وغيرها نبحث
مع الرئيس الانغولي رؤيته للهواجس المثاره
بشان العلاقات مع الصين وروسيا كما نحاول
استقراء الفرص الممكنه للدول الافريقيه
بفعل التنافس الدولي على قارتهم واحتمالات
تحول هذا التنفس الى صراع بين القوى
الكبرى مع ادريس ايات الاكاديمي الباحث
المتخصص في شؤون الافريقيه في جامعه
الكويت نساله عن دوافع الدول الافريقيه
للانفتاح على قوه عالميه اخرى غير القوى
الغربيه
عن مدى قدره الافارقه على التنسيق بينهم
لمواجهه التنافس الدولي على النفوذ على
اراضهم لكن لنشاهد القصه ونبدا بعدها
الحوار
2022 وخلال الاجتماع الطارئ للجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده للتصويت على قرار
مطالبه روسيا بوقف غزوها لاوكرانيا كانت
النتائج لافته للتغيرات استراتيجيه وصراع
نفوذ بين القوى الاقليميه في القاره
السمراء
افريقيا تمتلك 54 صوت في الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده هذا له تاثير مفيد لفاعلين
دوليين مختلفين خاصه الصين وروسيا اللتان
تحاولان التبرير افعالها
مهمه لروسيا ويمكن رؤيه ذلك جيدا من خلال
الطريقه التي تصوت بها الدول الافريقيه
حيث يتعين عليها التفكير مرتين قبل القبول
باي قرار من شانه ان يكون متعلقا
في الرابع والعشرين من يونيو كانت الجوله
الاولى لوزير الخارجيه الروسي منذ بدايه
الحرب الى افريقيا ثلاثها جوله لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي والتي كشفت صراع نفوذ
يمتد في القاره صرحت به الولايات المتحده
من خلال مشروع قانون مكافحه الانشطه
الروسيه الخبيثه في افريقيا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى مطلع القرن العشرين حيث بلغ
الاحتلال الاوروبي لافريقيا ذروته لتبدا
مرحله تحرر في ستينيات القرن الماضي تغير
معها شكل الاستعمار الضارب بجذوره في
انحاء القاره السمراء
ويحفف طفونالك 54 دوله افريقيه مستقله
وذات سياده ومع ذلك لا تزال افريقيا تتخبط
في طريق التنميه بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
تقريبا نصف الدول الافريقيه كانت مستعمره
من قبل فرنسا لكن العلاقه بين فرنسا وتلك
الدول استمرت حتى بعد الاستقلال
ديموغرافيا يبلغ عدد سكان افريقيا 1.3
مليار نسمه ومن المتوقع ان يتضاعف بحلول
2050 افريقيا تمتلك اقتصادا متناميا وتعد
مركزا للعديد من الطرق التجاريه لذلك
ستكون واحده من اكثر المناطق حيويه في
العالم تظهر الخريطه اهم نقاط حركه
التجاره العالميه والتي تتقاطع افريقيا مع
اربع نقاط من اصل ثمانيه حول العالم مما
يزيد اهميتها الاستراتيجيه وهو ما يفسر
التمركز القواعد العسكريه الغربيه في تلك
المواقع للحفاظ على السيطره على طرق
التجاره الدوليه امام كل ما يهدد مصالحها
في غينيا الاستوائيه اشارت تقارير
استخباراتيه الى ان الصين بدات في
الاستثمار في مشروع اعاده تاهيل وتوسيع
ميناء باته واقامه قاعده عسكريه وقد
اعتبرت الولايات المتحده ان القاعده
الصينيه تمثل تهديدا للامن القومي
الامريكي بالتزامن مع القاعده الصينيه في
جيبوتي على بعد عده اميال من القاعده
الامريكيه حيث تشير البيانات الى استثمار
الصين فيما لا يقل عن 46 ميناء في افريقيا
وضمن تمركزات تتيح الوصول الى مياه المحيط
الهادئ والاطلسي
هي الاستخدام المزدوج للموانئ حيث تبنيها
لاغراض تجاريه وكذلك تستغلها للدخول
العسكري والبحري ايضا
تعتمد تجاره الصين على الطرق والممرات
البحريه بنسبه 90% وهي الممر الاساسي
لوارداتها النفطيه ومن هنا يمكن فهم
استراتيجيه الحزام الواحد المكون من
اندماج طريق الحرير البري مع طريق الحرير
البحري الذي يغطي
63% من سكان العالم واكثر من
35% من تجاره البضائع عالميا ويمر ب 39
دوله افريقيه
[موسيقى]
الحزام والطريق عام 2013 ان الصين لا تبني
موانئ فقط في افريقيا لكنها تقوم ببناء
شريان كامل للنقل البري لربط افريقيا
الداخليه بالمنطقه الساحليه من خلال الطرق
السريعه
لدينا الان الكثير من مشاريع الطاقه
الكهرومائيه باموال صينيه لدينا نظام
الطريق التجاري الخفيف في اديس ابابا معظم
هذه المشاريع تستوعب الموارد الصينيه لان
الصينيين اولا ياتون بالمعاهدات مع راس
المال واثيوبيا تفتقر لراس المال ثانيا
تبيع الصين التقنيات مثل خدمه السكك
الحديديه او السدود الكهربائيه لقد قاموا
بحل المشكله الاساسيه وهي التمويل والصين
هنا تستفيد من تردد القمه
تجدها في كل الميادين فهي حاضره في جميع
المجالات في مجال البترول في البنيه
التحتيه مثل بناء الجسور من الواضح ان
الصينيين على استعداد لدخول اي مكان يكون
الاخرون غير مستعدين لدخوله اما شركات
الاوروبيين فهم اكثر حذرا مقارنه
[موسيقى]
راينا حجم الاستثمارات والقروض الى اخره
فنجد ان
اصبحت نوعا ما رهينه العلاقات الصينيه
الشعبيه ويصعب الخلاص منها لان
الصين طوقت تقريبا افريقيا ووصل الى مرحله
لارجو
لهذا
وبعد ان تبين ان الدول الافريقيه غير
قادره على سداد القروض التي اخذتها استغلت
الصين الفرصه وطالبت بضمانات لهذه القرب
حيث حصلت في بعض الحالات على الاصول
السياديه من تلك البلدان هناك قلق حقيقي
من النفوذ المفرط الذي تتمتع به الصين في
افريقيا
كان حقا عاما محوريا من حيث الاستثمار
الاجنبي المباشر في افريقيا بين الولايات
المتحده والصين واذا القينا نظره على
الاحصائيات سنجد ان الاستثمارات الصينيه
في افريقيا بعد 2022 بدات في تجاوز
الولايات المتحده واستمرت في الارتفاع
خلال العقد الماضي
بلغ حجم الاستثمارات الصينيه في افريقيا
نحو 34 وواحد من عشره مليار دولار خلال
السنوات العشر الاخيره مقابل ثمانيه واحد
مليار دولار للاستثمارات الامريكيه وتظهر
البيانات التنامي الاستثمارات الصينيه في
القاره بشكل مضطرد
[موسيقى]
لا يمكنك تجاهلها اذا كنت لاعبا عالميا
جدا هنالك صحوه الكل اصبح مهتما للعمل في
افريقيا
اعتراف الولايات المتحده بافريقيا
وامكانياتها للاقتصاديه وتنظيم تلك القمه
دفع الشركات الامريكيه للنظر اليها كفرصه
اذا تحدثنا مثلا عن اليورانيوم وتعدين
البترول والبلاتينيوم وغيرها سنجد ان اكثر
من 50% من الموارد العالميه تاتي من
افريقيا
تعد افريقيا مصدرا لنحو الثلاثين في المئه
من احتياطيات العالمي من المعادن وثمانيه
في المئه من الغاز الطبيعي واثني عشر في
المئه من احتياطيات النفط كما ان القاره
لديها 40% من الذهب العالمي ونحو 90% من
الكرومو البلاتين
نحن في بعض المعادن لا تتواجد الا في
افريقيا
الذي يدخل في تصنيع الاجهزه التليفون
وذهب تقريبا
نقطه جذب استراتيجي كله او التنافس القوى
هو الموارد الطبيعيه الافريقيه سواء تحت
الارض او فوق الارض او الموارد
الغابات تشكل النيجر مصدرا هاما للطاقه
النوويه لفرنسا حيث تمتلك 5% من احتياطات
العالم من اليورانيوم والتي تمثل 20% من
الوقود لمفاعلات فرنسا النوويه والتي
تعتمد عليها بشكل اساسي كمصدر من مصادر
الطاقه
في فرنسا مصدرها الطاقه النوويه والنيجر
هي الدوله الثالثه او الرابعه في العالم
في انتاج اليورانيوم مع هذا منذ
السبعينيات وحتى اللحظه لا نملك مبنى
واحدا في النيجر بنات فرنسا يسمى مثلا
مبنى اليورانيوم
اعتقد الافارقه ان الفرنسيين يستنزفون
مواردهم وللافارقه الحريه في اختيار
الشريك الروسي حيثما يميزنا هو غياب
الماضي الاستعماري
لان روسيا غير قادره على الاستثمار كثيرا
في افريقيا فهي ترى ان نقطه قوتها لدخول
القاره هي لعبوا على اوتار العداوات
القديمه حول الاستعمار فهذا يجعل فرنسا
تغادر ويفتح الباب لروسيا لتتغزل بافريقيا
استوريكا لدينا علاقات طويله مع فرنسا هذا
يعني اننا بالتاكيد لدينا علاقات مميزه
معها ولا يمكن انكار مساعداتها الامنيه
التي قدمتها لنا دعني اقول لدينا علاقات
استراتيجيه مع فرنسا وهذا شيء جيد
[موسيقى]
شهدت منطقه الساحل الافريقي تراجعا للحضور
الفرنسي حيث خرجت فرنسا من افريقيا الوسطى
منذ عام 2017 ومن مالي عام 2021 كما شهدت
النيجر وتشاد وبوركينا فاسو تظاهرات تطالب
بخروج فرنسا
[موسيقى]
ينظر بان الوجود المكثف للقوات الفرنسيه
والفرنسيين في داخل تشاد انما هو سلب
حقيقي للسياده الوطنيه
واستحواذ كامل على الثروات الخيرات
الوطنيه اما شارع تشادي فهو مع روسيا شارع
التشادي اليوم نكرهه شيء مسمى واحد اسمه
الوجود العسكري الفرنسي في تشاد تمثل
منطقه القرن الافريقي احد اهم المواقع
الاستراتيجيه في العالم حيث تمتلك اثنتا
عشره دوله اجنبيه قواعد ومنشات عسكريه
تتنافس على ايجاد موضع قدم لها الا ان
التواجد العسكري في افريقيا يحمل اشكالا
اخرى حيث تلعب الشركات الامنيه شبه
العسكريه ادوارا مختلفه داخل القاره
على المستوى الرسمي فان القياده الروسيه
لا علاقه لها بهذا الامر لكن ما هو غير
رسمي نعم ويمكن ان نقوله بهذه الصيغه ان
نشاط الشركات الخاصه الروسيه في افريقيا
يتم لصالح توجهات روسيا في القاره
في اي منطقه كانت فيها روسيا حاضره بقوه
ونشرت مرتزقه فاجنر كجزء من مجموعه
اسلحتها كانت تتسبب في مزيد من عدم
الاستقرار هذه
بالنسبه لعدم الاستقرار في الصحراء او في
غرب افريقيا لن اقول ان روسيا غير متورطه
في ذلك روسيا ليست منخرطه في ذلك بشكل
مباشر لكنها تخلق الظروف التي من خلالها
كانت قادره على استغلالها بشكل افضل من اي
طرف
بلغ حجم الانفاق العسكري في افريقيا نحو
43 واثنين من عشره مليار دولار في عام
2020 حيث استحوذت روسيا على
34% من واردات الاسلحه الى افريقيا تليها
الولايات المتحده والمانيا وفرنسا والصين
معظم الاعداد العسكري
هناك ايضا تطوير علاقات مع روسيا لكي
تستمر هذه هذه الاسلحه بين العمل التشغيل
الى اخره
[موسيقى]
بالتاكيد ستضر العقوبات الغربيه بتمويل
وشحن الاسلحه والسلع الاخرى لكن روسيا سوف
تجد طرقا اخرى لايصال هذه الاسلحه الى
البلدان الافريقيه
يشهد العالم تغيرا في موازين القوى وصعودا
لقوى جديده في اقليمها وربما تكون افريقيا
مسرحا لصراعات اكبر في المستقبل
في الواقع نحن بالفعل نشهد الحرب البارده
الجديده التي تدور الان بين روسيا من جهه
والدول الغربيه من جهه اخرى والساحه ليست
فقط في افريقيا
بدون لا نريد حربا بارده جديده ولا ان
تتحول افريقيا الى ساحه معركه عالميه نريد
تنافسا ضد الصينيين ليس من خلال توريد
الاسلحه ولكن من خلال توفير التكنولوجيا
وجلب الاستثناء
الكل يتجه الان نحو افريقيا ويقول هنا
المستقبل وهنا المكان الذي يجب ان يستثمر
فيه الجمال
لم يعد احد القطن يجب ان لا نتجاهل هذه
الحقيقه هناك انتقال مزدوج نحو عالم متعدد
الاقطار لا نتحدث فقط عن ثنائي القطن بل
حتى الثلاثي ورباعي هذا هو الواقع الان
امل ان يظهر قاده فارقه اقوياء لا يكون
تفوضهم على مصلحه شعوبهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الحديث عن هذا الموضوع موضوع التنافسات
الدوليه على القاره الافريقيه كنا قد
سالنا الرئيس
الانجليتشو في لقاء خاصه به برنامجا للقصه
بقيه سالناه عن الكيفيه التي تحدد بها
بلاده علاقاتها الدوليه مع المعسكر الغربي
ممثلا في الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي والقوه الدوليه الاخرى كروسيا
والصين وغيرهما نتابع
بعلاقات جيده مع كل بلد تقريبا في العالم
طبعا باستثناء تلك البلدان التي تعتبر
دولا منبوذه والتي هي لحسن الحظ ليست
كثيره في العالم
لذلك لدينا علاقات جيده مع ما يسمى بالدول
الغربيه
تماما كما لدينا علاقات جيده مع الصين
والقوه الاخرى مثل روسيا وتركيا والهند
هنديا في هذا يصب في مصلحه الدفاع عن
انجولا
لذا في علاقتنا مع الدول وجود علاقه جيده
مع بعض الدول لا يعني اننا نستثني وجود
علاقات جيده مع الدول الاخرى
عند الحديث عن هذه القوه الصاعده فان
لدينا ايضا علاقات جيده مع دول الشرق
الاوسط بشكل عام
وكذلك مع دول امريكا اللاتينيه والدول
الاسيويه لدينا سياسه خارجيه منفتحه
للغايه ولا نريد ارتكاب الاخطاء التي
ارتكبت خلال فتره الحرب البارده عندما كان
العالم منقسما الى معسكري لمتباينين تماما
كما سالنا الرئيس الانغولي عن نظره انجولا
الى الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه الجديده تجاه
افريقيا ويبدو فيها تركيز اكبر على
الجوانب التنمويه والاقتصاديه وهل تمت
علاقه بين هذه الاستراتيجيه والحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه
حسنا ارغب في الخوض كثيرا في هذا الجانب
من السبب والنتيجه
فقط ان اقول ان التعاون مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه موضع ترحيب كبير لذا
لدينا علاقات ممتازه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ونعمل على جعل هذه العلاقات
افضل
الجيد اجراء هذه المقارنه لان القاره
الافريقيه ملك للافارقه
ولا يمكن لاي شخص غير افريقي ان يشعر بانه
يمتلك افريقيا
روسيا
والصين تحت جيزان افريقيا كراهينه وان دول
العالم الاخرى لا يمكنها اختراق افريقيا
هذا ليس صحيحا
فالغرب كان موجودا في افريقيا لاكثر من
خمسه قرون لاكثر من 500 عام وما زالوا
موجودين
لذا من الخطا القول ان الصين وروسيا
تتعاملان مع افريقيا عمليا كراهين كقاره
تابعه لهم
افريقيا ليست قاره اي شخص اخر بل هي قاره
الافارقه انفسهم
باي شخص يريد القدوم الى افريقيا ليس
الاستعمارنا ولكن لمساعدتنا في تنميتنا من
خلال جلب الاستثمار الخاص قبل كل شيء
اما عن سؤالنا عن مدى تاثر علاقات بلاده
الاقتصاديه مع القوى الكبرى في ظل مناخ
الاستقطاب العالمي بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
والتجاذب بين روسيا
واشنطن والصين فكان هذا رده
اظن انها تؤثر فهي لا تؤثر بقدر تاثير
الحرب نفسها فحرب اوكرانيا تؤثر على
التوتر بين القوى العظمى الثلاث الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا والصين
لكن التوتر نفسه لا يؤثر على بلداننا
هي لا تؤثر لانه فيما يخص العلاقه مع
الصين فنحن نتحدث عن دوله مقابل دوله
وتعاون جيده معنا مع انغولا وهنا نحن
نتحدث عن انجولا على وجه التحديد ولا اريد
ان اتحدث بشكل عام عن القاره
فكل دوله قائمه بذاتها
ليس لدينا استثمارات صينيه خاصه كبيره في
بلدنا على عكس ما يقال فالصين لديها
الكثير من الاستثمارات الخاصه في اوروبا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن في
انغولا على وجه الخصوص وفي افريقيا بشكل
عام ليس لديها ذلك وعلى حد علمنا الصين
ليس لديها الكثير من الاستثمارات الخاصه
ما حدث مع انغولا هو انجولا اضطرت الى
مواجهه حرب اهليه طويله لما يقرب من ثلاثه
عقود نتج عنها تدمير البلاد بشكل كبير
ودمرت بنيتها التحتيه بالكامل تقريبا وكان
هناك حديث عن عقد مؤتمر للمانحين في
بروكسل لاعاده الاعمال الوطني لانجولا كان
ذلك في نهايه الحرب لكن في عام 2002 لم
يعقد ذلك المؤتمر لسوء الحظ ولاسباب غير
معروفه لنا
فعرضت علينا الصين تمويل اعاده
التحتيه وتم التفاوض على شروط التمويل ولم
يتم فرضها في ذلك الوقت واحيانا يجري حديث
عن فخ الديون الصينيه لا اعتقد ذلك لا
اعتقد انه فخر
عندما يتم تفاوض على شيء ما يتحمل كل من
الطرفين مسؤوليته ولا يمكن ان يعد هذا فخا
وفي ذلك الوقت من عام 2002 كان الخيار لنا
للقبول او الرفض حيث تم اغلاق كافه
الابواب الاخرى
وبدلا من الحديث عن فخ الديون مع الصين
اود القول ان شروط التمويل في ذلك الوقت
لم تكن الافضل لبلدنا لكن ذلك حل لمشكله
لاننا بهذا التمويل تمكنا من استعاده
البنى التحتيه الرئيسيه والط والجسور
والسكك الحديديه والموانئ وما الى ذلك
لكن الاتفاق لم يكن الافضل لنا لحقيقه
انهم حصلوا مقابل ذلك على النفط
حيث استلموا بشكل منتظم شحنات النفط
الخامات
نحن نحاول تصحيح نموذج التمويل هذا لذا
نحن لا نتعاقد على ديون جديده مع الصين
على اساس المقابل
[موسيقى]
النفطيش موديل لكن هذا النموذج للتعاقد
على الديون بضمانات النفطيه لم يحدث فقط
مع الصين حدث ذلك ايضا مع البرازيل على
سبيل المثال
لقد استفدنا من التمويل البرازيلي من خلال
بنك التنميه ايضا لاعاده تاهيل البنيه
التحتيه وبالتالي استفادت انغولا من ذلك
لكن شروطه واحكام هذا التمويل كانت مطابقه
لتلك التي وقعتها انغولا مع الصين
ايضا لا ينبغي ان يكون الامر على هذا
النحو
ولكن الغريب انه تم ذكر الصين فقط لا اعرف
ما اذا كان السبب هو حجم الدين الذي هو
كبير جدا مقارنه بالديون التي ترتبت علينا
في حاله البرازيل
لكني اود ايضا ان اغتنم هذه الفرصه لاقول
انه فيما يتعلق بضيوننا لبنك التنميه
البرازيلي فقد سددنا ديوننا اي قمنا
بتصفير ديوننا وفي ديسمبر 2021 حتى في
منتصف فتره كوفيد دفعنا للبرازيل اخر 900
مليون دولار
والتي كان علينا دفعها قبل عام 2024
كان علينا تسديده قبل عام 2024 سددناه
بالكامل في ديسمبر 2021
في نهايه المطاف اذا قمنا بانشاء عقود
ديون جديده مع الصين فستكون الشروط الى حد
ما مختلفه اي انها لن تكون على اساس
المقابل النفطي
تحدث باسهاب عن الصين لكن ما مجالات
التعاون بين انجولا وروسيا التي اكد وزير
خارجيتها خلال زيارته انغولا الالتزام
المتبادل الثابت بالتنميه في جميع
المجالات بين البلدين
حسنا يجب ان نكون صريحين من خلال ذكر ان
مجالات التعاون مع روسيا محدوده للغايه
تتعاون مع انغولا خاصه في مجال الدفاع
والامن
وهي تزود القوات المسلحه الانغوليه
بالمعدات العسكريه على مر السنين
وبطبيعه الحال فان ذلك مصحوب ايضا بتدريب
الافراد الذين يتعاملون مع المعدات
والمدفعيه والدبابات والطيران وما الى ذلك
العديد
ممن تم تدريبهم في روسيا
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بالتعاون الاقتصادي فهو ضئيل
واؤكد انه في حده الادنى
الوجود الروسي في الاقتصاد الانغولي
ستلمسه في قطاع الموارد المعدنيه
وبشكل اكثر تحديدا في استكشاف
صخور الالماس
لاسيما من خلال شركه كاتوكا للتعديل
حيث تقوم شركه الروسيه الى جانب شركه
الالماس الحكوميه الانغوليه الخاصه بنا
باستكشاف الالماس وفي الاونه الاخيره مع
اطلاق انغوسا 2 القمر الصناعي الانغولي
الذي صنعه قطاع صناعه الفضاء الروسي
وهو مجال اخر للتعاون بيننا وبين روسيا
بخلاف ذلك لا يوجد عمليا باستثناء كتوكا
اي استثمار روسي خاص في انغولا
رغم هذا الجواب الحينا بالسؤال عن النفود
الروسي ففي مارس من العام الماضي خلال
تصويت بالجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
اختارت 26 دوله من بين 54 دوله افريقيه
اما الغياب او الامتناع او رفض مشروع قرار
ادانه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وقد
سالنا الرئيس الانغولي الى اي حد يعكس هذا
التصويت قوه النفوذ الروسي في افريقيا
فكان جوابه
الجمعيه الجمعيه الامم المتحده في مارس
اذار من العام الماضي في الواقع امتنعت
انغولا عن التصويت
عن التصويت لان الحرب لم يكن قد مضى شهر
على نشوبها
وكنا بحاجه الى فهم افضل للاتجاه الذي
ستتخذه هذه الحرب
صحيح ان كل حرب سيئه ويجب ادانتها لكن
الامتناع ايضا لا يعني الموائمه الامتناع
يعني عدم الانحياز لاي موقف
لذلك لا يمكن تفسير الموقف على انه دفاع
عن الحرب نحن لا ندافع عن الحرب لو دفعنا
عن الحرب في اوكرانيا لكن قد صوتنا ضد
القرار
هذا نفسه قدمته الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كما فعلت بعض البلدان وعدد قليل
من البلدان في العالم لذلك لم تفعل انغول
ذلك
ولكن سيكون من السيء التركيز فقط على
اجتماع الامم المتحده في اذار مارس لانه
بعد اجتماع ادار مارس كان هناك اجتماع اخر
كان لانغولا فيه موقف مختلف تماما
في تلك المناسبه ولا اذكر التاريخ بدقه
لكننا صوتنا لصالح قرار الامم المتحده
الذي ادانا ضمن مناطق دومباس الاربع من
قبل روسيا
موقف واضح للغايه في ادانه ضم جزء من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من قبل روسيا
وفي ختم لقاء الرئيس الانغولي مع برنامج
للقصه بقيه سالناه عن مدى قدره الدول
الافريقيه على تحقيق شركات عادله مع القوى
الكبرى لتجنب تحول القاره الى ساحه تنافس
قد يضر في نهايه الامر بالمصالح الافريقيه
المنافسه ليست سيئه
نحن لسنا خائفين من المنافسه بين بعضنا
البعض
المنافسه صحيه
ليس سوى منافسه اقتصاديه ومنافسه تجاريه
بين القوتين
وهذا امر جيد للاقتصادات نفسها عند
التنافس
المنافسه الوحيده غير جيده هي المنافسه
العسكريه اي سباق التسلح
هذه منافسه مدمره معكم
من كانت هذه مقابلتنا مع الرئيس الانجولي
اما الان وفي هذا الجزء من هذه الحلقه
والحوار نرحب بضيفنا من الكويت السيد
ادريس ايات الاكاديمي والباحث المتخصص في
شؤون الافريقيه في جامعه الكويت سيد ادريس
تابعت معنا هذا اللقاء الذي خصنا به
الرئيس الانغولي في ختامه تحدث بان هذا
التنافس الدولي والاهتمام الدولي بالقاره
الافريقيه ليس سيئا بل على العكس يمكن ان
تستفيد منه دول القاره الافريقيه كيف تراه
انت في اي سياق ترى هذا الاهتمام بعد
الاهمال
مساكم الله بالخير شكرا على الاستضافه
السيده فيروز
اولا اريد ان اشير الى ان
التغطيه كانت رائعه جدا على هذا التنافس
لا يمكن ان نزيد اكثر على هذا الموضوع
نشكركم على هذه التغذيه الرائعه بقناتنا
هذا من طرف اخر اعتقد ان هذا الاهتمام
يجب ان يصب ايضا في الاستشرافات
المستقبليه التي بدات منذ 2010 الى 2020
مثلا في 2017 مثلا الكاتب والسياسي
الاوروبي جانو قال ان القاره الافريقيه هي
اهم حدث البشريه في القرن الحادث
والانشرين في القرن الحادي والعشرين
باعتباري انه في غدوني 25 عاما فقد ستكون
القاره الافريقيه عدد السكان فيها مليار
ونصف من البشريه ما يمثل 40% من سكان
العالم هذه القوه لا يمكن اهمالها
وتتجانب هذه
القوه الديموغرافيه ما ان عشر اكبر مدن
الاسرى نموا في القاره في العالم ايضا
جميعها موجوده في القاره الافريقيه فنان
نتحدث عن قوه ديموغرافيه واحتماليه قوه
اقتصاديه ما تقريبا ثلث سكان العالم هذا
الكم الهائل لا يمكن لا يمكن تجنبه لا
اقتصاديا ولا يمكن احماله لا سياسيا ولا
جيو
اقتصاديا هذا من جانب ما ذكرته ايضا فيه
تقريركم فيما يتعلق
بالمعادن الاستراتيجيه المهمه للابتكارات
التكنولوجيه ايضا اغلبها موجوده في القاره
الافريقيه لكن الكلمه السر في وجهه
النظريه في هذا السياق هي الصين
التعاون الصيني الافريقي بدا في القرن
العشرين لكن
الحدث الاكبر كان بدايه الالفيه الثالثه
ما المنتدى الاقتصادي الصيني الافريقي
كان
الكلمه السر التي جالت الكوى الكبرى كلها
تتوجه نوى الكره الافريقيه باعتبار ان
النموذج الصيني في التقرب مع الاكار
الافريقيه مختلفه جدا لما كانت موجوده مع
فرنسا سابقا ويابان التي بدات في ثلاثه
وتسعين
قوه
لكن الصين ليست اللاعب الوحيد نرى الان
يعني هجوم وهجمه على الافريقيه تابعنا في
التقنيه وفي المقدمه ايضا تحدثنا عن هذا
الموضوع
روسيا ايضا موجوده في القاره الافريقيه
الهند تركيا ماليزيا البرازيل وغيرها دون
ان نغفل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي
كانت لها قمه ايضا امريكيه افريقيه سنه
الماضيه
نعم
صحيح الصين ليست الدوله الوحيده اردت ان
انطلق من هذه النقطه للقول بان الصين هي
الدفعه التي جعلت تلك القوى جميعها تتجه
نحو القاره الافريقيه لماذا مثلا المنتدى
الافريقي الصيني كان في عام 2000 مباشره
في عام 2008
بدات اذا القمه الافريقيه التركيه في 2008
ثم نتحدث مباشره في 2014 بعد غياب طويل
للولايات المتحده وخاصه المجال الاقتصادي
والاستثمار بالتحديد 2014 بدات القمه
الاولى الامريكيه الامريكيه في 2014
بقياده باراك اوباما الثانيه كان في
ديسمبر ما اداره الرئيس جو بايدن فنعم
جميعها موجوده يمكن الحديث انها باسهاب
والتنافس فيما بينها وميزه نظري جيده
للقاره الافريقيه لكن الصين وخاصه اذا
رايت الاستاذه جميع التوجهات نحو
الافريقيه من الكيوي المذكوره كانها ردود
فعل وخاصه من قبل فرنسا ثم ايضا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وحتى تركيا
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه لمواجهه روسيا
التي اعلن عنها اداره الرئيس جو بايدن
قانون التنافس الابتكار لمذاكفه الصين هي
اصلا الهدف منه لمنافسه الصين اذا الصين
هي التي فتحت كل هؤلاء
النظر ربما بعين اخرى للقاره الافريقيه مع
كل الثروات مثل ما كنت تتحدث الديموغرافيه
والطبيعيه
المختلفه ثروات الموجوده فيها السؤال ربما
كيف يمكن ان يستفيد الافارقه من هذا
الاهتمام باعتقادك يعني كل الذين استطلعنا
ارائهم في الفيلم او حتى الرئيس الانجلي
تحدث عن ضروره حفاظ هذه الدول على
سياداتهم ما الذي يضمن عدم انتقال تبع يه
هذه الدول الافريقيه من طرف الى طرف اخر
من مستعمرات قديمه يبدو انه قد لفضتها
غالبيه هذه الدول الافريقيه الى دول اخرى
لها مطامع ومقارب ربما في افريقيا
سؤال رائع جدا لانه يتكرر علي اكثر من مره
ومن خبراء صحفيين ايضا محترمين امثالكم
وامثالكن سيدتي اولا الحديث عن الكار
الافريقيه من حيثيه التبعيه من قاره اخرى
او خروج من احضان سيد الى سيد اخر
اعتقد انه مبالغه اضافه الى ان اذا تصريح
ينم ان قله ادراك بالقاره الافريقيه
وعلاقتها الجديده اضيف الى ذلك ان ايضا
فيه جانب من الانصريه فالحديث ان العلاقات
الصينيه مع الدول الاسيويه اندونيسيا
ماليزيا وغيرها لاحد يتحدث ان خروجي من
سيد الى سيد اخر مثلا حتى الزياره الاخيره
للرئيس السينيسي جنبي الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تحدثوا عن علاقات كذلك ايضا
ايطاليا الاستثمار الدين الصيني اتجاه
ايطاليا قرابه 80 دولار تقريبا نصف مجموع
الصيني للكره الافريقيه لكنهم يتحدثون عن
خروج من الاباء السيدة الى سيد اخر كان
القاره الافريقيه هي او مجموعه من بضائع
او عبيد يبحثون عن اسياد وهذا التصريخ خطا
جدا
ومزدوج
عن الصين
في الحديث عنها تماما كما الرئيس الانغولي
ومختلف الاراء في قاره افريقيا والصين قد
وضعت بالفعل ثقلها في العديد من الدول
الافريقيه من شمالها الى جنوبها ومن شرقها
الى غربها هناك من يحذر في الواقع من فخ
الديون الافريقيه يعني عفوا الصينيه الصين
ليست بريئه تماما يا تريد ان تسترزق والتي
هي تريد ان ان تربح كيف السبيل ربما ان
يستفيد الطرفان من الموضوع وضمان الحقوق
في هذه الحاله وهذا هو السؤال
نعم الحقيقه ان الاستثمار الصيني الهائل
يعتبر ايضا خطر من جوانب عده
مثلا السيوله الهائله الموجوده لدى
الشركات الصينيه المدعومه من الحكومات
تختلف عن الشركات الخاصه الاوروبيه وهذا
بالضبط او الغربيه وهذا بالضبط الفارق
الكبير لكن هذا يؤدي يؤدي بنا ممكن الحديث
الى مبادره الحزام والطريق باعتبار ان هذه
المبادره
تستفيد منها القاره الافريقيه لكن في نفس
الوقت ايضا الصين السيول الهائله التي
توفرها الصين وتداها للطاوله
تجعل من المفاوضات في صالح الصين اكثر
منها في الدول القاره الافريقيه اضيفي الى
ذلك ان في قوانين اغلب القوانين الصفقات
التي قراتها والتعاقدات تجبر الصين تلك
الدول على الاحتكام الى القوانين التجاريه
الصينيه مثلا
نعم هذا هذا من جانب جانب اخر النسيم اذا
تترك الولاء المطلق مقابل الاستثماراتها
هذا الولاء المطلق عندما ترفض الدوله
معينه مثل ما حدث في زامبيا يتم التسكيل
او التسعيب هيكله الدفع والديون وهذا
بالضبط ثم اتحدث عنه في فخذ دبلوماتيه فخذ
الديون مثلا المطار استخدمت زامبيا المطار
الدولي
كاسول لاعاده هيكله والدفع القروض للصين
واضح تمام دفع الرئيس
ماذا لو تحدثنا قليلا عن روسيا الرئيس
الانغولي قال بان نفوذها محدود وحصلوا في
الجانب الامني والعسكري روسيا التي تنتقد
الولايات المتحده ايضا وجودها في القاره
الافريقيه الان امام هذه اللاعبين الثلاث
على الاقل كبار نتحدث عن روسيا والصين
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ايهم تعتقد بانه ستكون له الغلبه في
الكعكه الافريقيه ان صح التعبير
نعم اولا يمكن الحديث ايضا اند روسيا في
هذا الجانب لكن الطريقه الروسيه كما
وصفتها الولايات المتحده بانها خبيثه يمكن
ان
نختلف عن التسميه لكن صراحه روسيا تستخدم
طرق مايكافيليه بالرجوع الى النارات
السابقه وهذه ايضا لها ايضا لها حكايتها
التاريخيه وكذلك ما القاره الافريقيه وخسا
وخاصه مال الجيل الصيد الذي لم يعيش فتره
الاستثمار لكنها قرات كثيرا عن الفترات
الاشتراكات للانسان الابيض وخاصه الاوروبي
للاقر الافريقيه
فالروسيه تعمل على هذا الجانب بالتحديد
مثلا ياخذ مثال افريقيا الوسطى لم تتمرد
على فرنسا الا بعدما دخلت فيها فرنسا وردت
ايضا الى احد من استخدام فرنسا ومناجمها
من الماس والذهب
لاثراء
اوروبا وخاصه فرنسا
نقص تجد القاره الافريقيه وخاصنا الدول
الفرنكيه كلها فقيره لا توجد دوله افريقيه
فيها بنيه تحتيها يمكن تشار اليها فتشكر
فرنسا على ذلك وروسيا تدرك ذلك فتلعب على
هذا الجانب بالتحديد هذا ما ادى بفرنسا
الى تسميه هذا
في الصحف وكذلك في المقالات بمعادات سياسه
بمعادات فرنسا اما فيما يتالق بالولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ارتكبت اخطاء
استراتيجيه
بارتكاذها الى المجال الامني كثيرا ومعلك
وامهلت كيف يقال واحملت الجانب الاقتصادي
مثلا القواعد العسكريه والمنشاءات
العسكريه والمحميات العسكريه موجوده في
القاره الافريقيه تقريبا في اكثر من
ثلاثين دوله بينما في الجانب الاقتصادي
وهذا هو ما يحتاج القاره الافريقيه البنيه
التحتيه بالتحديد احملتها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لكنها تداركتها مؤخرا
وهذا الذي يفسر الاستراتيجيه الجديده التي
تحاول ايضا ان تلعب ادوارا لكن انا اعتقد
الهند ماليزيا البرازيل اليابان وغيرها
كيف يمكن باعتقادك ان تؤثر ربما في مجره
التنافس بين القوى الكبرى الثلاثه التي
كنا نتحدث عنها
هذا يتعلق بالولاءات اذا والتحالفات لكن
اغلب الدول المذكوره حاليا تتحالف بطريقه
ما او باخرى مع الولايات المتحده والقوى
الغربيه باعتبار ان حكوماتها ليست
اوتوكولاتيه كليا كما يرد روسيا والصين
للرجوع الى سؤالك القديمه من يمكن ان يكون
لها الغلبه انا من وجهه النظر وليس من حب
او ان
ولاء لدوله معينه لكن اعتقد ان السيد تسرف
اكثر وخاصه الاموال اكثر من الدول الاخرى
مثلا اخر قمه صينيه افريقيه اثمرت ان 200
مليار دولار للدول الافريقيه بينما القمه
الامريكيه الامريكيه 55 مليار دولار فقط
عندما 55 مليار دولار في ثلاث سنوات نتحدث
عن تقريبا
كل سنه الدوله مثل نيجيريا العملاق
الافريقي واكبر واكبر اقتصاد في القاره
الافريقيه باكثر من 500 مليار ماذا تفيدها
ثم انتشر مليون دولار في السنه ممتاز وضحت
وجهه نظرك تماما وهي تتلاقى بالف
التحليلات التي قراناها ومختلف وجهات
النظر ايضا التي اوردناها الصين لعلها هي
الفائز الاكبر بالتورته الافريقيه خاصه
بمبادرتها الحزام والطريق وهي تفطنت مبكرا
من يصل اولا ربما هو من يفوز اخرا الختام
اشكره ضيفي الكريم للسيد ادريس ايات
الاكاديمي والباحث المتخصص في الشؤون
الافريقيه في جامعه الكويت كما نشكر ضيفنا
الذي سجلنا معه لقاء رئيس
الانغولينسو الى اللقاء مع بقيه لقصه
جديده الاسبوع القادم باذن الله السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]